next question from Becca do you think
space tourism will be possible in the
next 50 years I don't know what were
you're envisioning Becca when you say
space tourism but I believe that some
form of space tourism will absolutely be
available and possible in the next 50
years because you can already kind of
buy a trip into space so if you think
about how quickly technology is
accelerating and prices are coming down
I have no doubt that something that
would qualify as space tourism will
definitely be available in the next 50
years now will you be able to go up and
stay in some space hotel for a week with
great amenities and a spa and whatever I
don't know about that but fifty a lot
can happen in 50 years yeah I wonder if
Newt Gingrich's moon colony idea will
have been realized at that point I guess
it really kind of depends I don't know
it seems like we're we're giving a NASA
less of a priority now in our own budget
but given people like Elon Musk you know
and another you know private
entrepreneurs or are kind of putting
this at the forefront of their agenda I
mean it could be possible you know
there's a huge now movement of private
companies working on this and yeah I
like Neil deGrasse Tyson support NASA I
believe we should fund NASA and think
it's actually a really good investment
of money versus just repurchasing the
same missiles because they've quote
expired but yeah private industry now is
getting involved in this and I think
that we're gonna see huge progress I
think in the next 15 years that we may
have much more widely available forms of
space tourism and in the next 50 years
absolutely unless something goes really
wrong unless Trump does way more damage
than even we think you might do my
instinct is to be rather skeptical but
I'm sure if you had asked me about
self-driving cars ten years ago I would
have called you out even to even five
years ago maybe there's still people in
our audience who tell me that
self-driving cars will never happen of
course they already exist